whoa house to go and rest my name is
Pierre Dubois and welcome to fear
amnesia
this is actually kind of creepy I'll
take you up you might notice I have a
heartbeat sensor and it's kind of cool
when I'm relaxed I'd say it's about 80
and it's already pretty [ __ ] high so
Chase is [ __ ] penis I if you had I
asked one probably the birds have been
saying play amnesia and here I am so you
should be pretty [ __ ] happy right now
don't you fear are you afraid of the
dark or you willing certify do you think
you are brave enough do you think you
are able to find the truth nobody will
ever know what happened here
candy I don't think I got what do you
think mr. Schine you can't you ha ha ha
Daria well [ __ ] this is this is a
terrible sorry I'm not supposed to build
up man it's supposed to build up and
[ __ ] it's supposed to this cousins are
supposed to test you on like your how
you how you [ __ ] [ __ ] no that's not
what it was and what something else hi
how you react to fear and stress and
should have why Stefano oh thank Jesus a
sanity potion I need that can't move
with these shades first I have to
explore okay well this time to explore
[ __ ] my pulses out of [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello a gentleman gave him a kiss Gabe
it's just breathing it's just breathing
we're [ __ ] what happened there knock
there has to be a good [ __ ] penis oh
we're going down we going out it's fine
we're fine we're fine breasts or fine
someone out there what's happening I
don't even know breasts I don't even
[ __ ] know what what happened that was
probably just the wind probably let's
climb up this I don't even know what's
going on right now all I know is I'm
climbing bookshelves oh it's a key
underneath it's one place [ __ ] Oh what
do we don't think I can tell you but
don't know it's stuck all right well we
have oil but we don't have any penis I'm
sorry was that it does that [ __ ] it
all right no that was fun
all right I guess we did I guess we're
just gonna go down your [ __ ] barrels
what happened in the basement
stays in the basement
I don't even know anymore breasts I
really don't even know anymore what the
[ __ ] is going on here it's custom sorry
I just want to [ __ ] me over it doesn't
Hey
alright what good start
you [ __ ] ah sorry about that
what am i doing what okay so so much
stuff happening I can't even react to it
what my pulse went down from that I need
another [ __ ] G well it's what they
say you fear the unknown somebody
actually [ __ ] is not happening maybe
your pulse is higher I don't know period
lovely I don't fear period though never
been
ouch extreme heat okay well a [ __ ]
lantern would it's [ __ ] splendid
right now it's kinda hard to merge
myself it's the [ __ ] feels like this
random [ __ ] just happens every day
what see what I'm talking about okay
okay that won't work that's what
actually what holy [ __ ]
lady nice [ __ ] what I meant her catch
I'm a dad yesterday
his name was Felix - we had a good time
together alright some obviously lacking
keys here I did find cheese and [ __ ] are
you okay as a tinderbox
all right let me go let me go back up
then we go back up and see if we can
find something breast off your fun
Damien's is really good in this one the
force is strong with this one all right
no fight we're just gonna go here I feel
like there's something in the Attic I
think I saw a key in the cleaning room
the bucket fell with water it's singing
the planks are in the way let's get rid
of Oh Oh Tac Toe rigored fidei hello are
yinz
whoa Sir Guy there I don't even know
anymore breaths
I feel better now that I have my lad you
know mr. show I need your help bro we're
gonna clear out this boy yeah but I did
not work it's the way I planned it
all right we're going down then we're
going [ __ ] down he said he saw a key
in the cleaning room but I'm not where
the [ __ ] is the cleaning room there is
the cleaning room what Oh
Oh Jay says machine room key all right
that's got to be downstairs right all
right sit here let me just check Sunday
and I might oil good [ __ ] splendid I
haven't got breasts
dad we go [ __ ] this face man
[ __ ]
alright alright alright what is it
where is that why right side
Wow that's dad what words run around now
you will not forget it or know about the
couch it's me why I got we're sorry
Batman
ryback's back oh you try to hide [ __ ]
from me [ __ ]
don't think I didn't see that it's
extreme heat extreme all right fine all
right please work
yeah that's gotta be it no Jen put end
of this all right
like matching
put tapas alright Prez I'm back I don't
think I can't figure out the machine
room thing right now so we're gonna go
look over here instead it also says here
I'm feeling very strange lately
so I locked myself in this room I don't
want to hurt people just leave me alone
son of a man an atom bomb is in there
what the [ __ ] Joey what the hell what a
woman what was every sound in this game
seriously my pulse is in the high so I
guess that means we're fine
if I can't find a bucket I can fill it
with water
oh and then I can use it on the fire I'm
a genius all right what's happening
forest what's up what you want to do
with me I don't understand the pulse
thing
sometimes when I'm not don't feel scared
it's [ __ ] I am sometimes when I feel
scared it doesn't have any effect at all
well where's my bucket where it's my
[ __ ] bucket and why can I walk
over here
well what happened here it's open now Oh
what the [ __ ]
sniffs I got a hammer now damn I have no
idea where I put the key last time in
one of my shirts and things I can
remember oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you know what
like you're coming with me
you're a so fine and sexy thank you baby
I just shaved my legs that is really
nice information I really appreciate
that you told me that alrighty then
well we're going back up where we're
taught leg I don't even get like [ __ ] me
[ __ ] what how does that even possible
I'm out of here oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me
all right we're going back I get back I
get back I get back to where you once
belong this isn't so bad I'm just
walking to our door
I bet the door will slam in my face and
say hey your pair they you're not
allowed in my house [ __ ] door
betrayed me man that son of a [ __ ] I
don't even know what's going on here
best
I just need Savano I need all my friends
I need you are you scared I forgot to
ask you are you scared I can see on your
face you should see it it's quite
hilarious quite humorous
oh [ __ ] my deck no way what to fine
alright well that was nice
there should be some plaque a sip time
yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] mr. shirt what did you
know here to go
what the [ __ ] is going on okay okay stop
habitat why not
what am I supposed to do with this
otherwise now listen and go as planned
hi nunu nunu anemones jab let me get new
top of the jam you live time why do I
need the hammer these planks are away
must get rid of them somehow well
however this [ __ ] bad-ass hammer I
thought that would work for sure [ __ ] my
mr. Sherr we're going I need you baby
that's right kids
I'm your lovin I'm your Mac love out
parents be careful my body's tender stay
there
all right brothers I'm gonna have to end
this episode here because I don't know
let me know what you think about the
heartbeat sensor thing I hope we worked
out pretty well anyway like and favorite
if you enjoyed subscribe Cobra today and
I'll see you next episode know that I
make every breath sounds
[Music]
so now I get to you
this tastes like tomato sauce mixed with
fix it again give it a 8.5
[Music]